[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
muchas gracias a todos por estar acá
yo siempre creo en los motivos
metafísicos astrofísicos como sea que se
diga esas palabras complicadas que hacen
que tantas personas estemos reunidas en
el mismo lugar no sé si hay una razón
o no lo vamos a averiguar pero sí me
parece que existe algo superior que nos
junta con un propósito
en esta ocasión los compañeros antes me
han dejado con una vara bien alta porque
justamente nos han hablado de
aproximaciones a nuestras relaciones
interpersonales y hoy día sí les voy a
hablar de un tema que es un poco cursi
porque cuando nos preguntamos qué hace a
una sociedad diferente o que la mejora
yo sí creo que la amabilidad es la
respuesta
he tenido la oportunidad de viajar por
varios lugares y conocer a personas de
distintas creencias ideologías
y lo que he encontrado de común es que
en el alma humana hay algo que nos mueve
y es el deseo de ser amados ustedes
pueden ir afuera y tratar de verlo todos
tenemos aunque no lo reconocemos ese
deseo de ser amados aceptados y
reconocidos y además en el transcurso de
preparar esta charla decidí hacer un
experimento y entonces hice un google
forms y lo lancé a una muestra chiquita
de 500 personas con la pregunta qué
crees que le hace falta al mundo y
entonces de estas 497 personas más de la
mitad respondía que nos falta amor
bondad ser más buenos y entonces yo
decía guau parece que todos tenemos esta
idea que adentro pero nadie se atreve a
decirlo
nadie se atreve a decir que necesitamos
más amor y menos odio
menos sodio menos darnos la espalda
menos hacernos la guerra menos
lastimarnos la vida ya es lo
suficientemente dura está llena de
sufrimiento de batallas de problemas
entonces al menos en quienes nos rodean
en esta comunidad que somos nosotros
deberíamos poder encontrar apoyo saber
que no estamos solos
de entre todas las opciones ser malo es
la más fácil
es la más fácil porque es bien fácil
encontrar excusas es bien fácil
justificar nos y desde que somos
pequeños nos han enseñado a ponernos en
el rol de víctima y cuando nos ponemos
en el rol de víctima cuando culpamos a
los otros de nuestras propias actitudes
y decimos yo soy malo porque tú eres
malo y te insulto porque tú me insultas
y soy violenta porque mi padre fue
violento no es mi culpa y yo quiero que
te des cuenta que vivir bajo esta lógica
es una forma fabulosa de perder tu
libertad si lo que hacen o dejan de
hacer los otros define quién eres te has
perdido los demás ejercen poder sobre ti
entonces cuando te dan este típico
consejo no seas bueno si él te ha hecho
cosas lo peor aunque seas lo igualito
te están dando el más triste de los
consejos porque vivimos en una sociedad
que normaliza la violencia y que nos
enseña y nos condiciona a responder a la
violencia con más violencia y al odio
con más odio y sin embargo no se puede
apagar el fuego echando leña
es verdad que existe gente mala sería
ingenuo no saberlo por eso el desafío es
ser bueno a pesar de que los otros sean
malos ser amable a pesar de que los
otros no lo sean ser suaves justamente
porque conocemos la crueldad humana y
los límites impensables a los que puede
llegar ayudar a los demás precisamente
porque a nosotros nadie nos ayudó cuando
más lo necesitábamos
justamente porque nadie nos ayudó cuando
más lo necesitábamos quiero que te des
cuenta que aunque todos te apoyan en la
idea de que el otro es culpable obvio el
taxista que se metió mientras manejaba
si casi te hace chocar es el culpable de
tu enojo no es él eres tú tú eres el
único responsable de sentirte cómo te
sientes entonces quiero pedirles eso
quiero pedirnos porque me incluyo que
nos hagamos responsables de nosotros
mismos
y en esto de hacernos responsables
hacernos responsables de nosotros mismos
podemos decidir qué cargas queremos
seguir llevando qué cargas de odio de
rencor
queremos seguir cargando y de cuales nos
queremos liberar y entonces aprendemos a
perdonar y perdonamos a los que nos
lastimaron a los que nos lastiman y a
los que nos van a seguir lastimando
porque estas personas van a seguir
existiendo
y lo hacemos porque la amabilidad es
acerca de disolver el ego y ya no se
trata sólo de mí a mí me han hecho a mí
me han dicho pobrecito yo yo yo yo sino
que eres capaz de volcar al otro mirarlo
observarlo sin juzgarlo
y darte cuenta de que esta persona ya
tiene las suficientes batallas y te
preguntas cuando alguien no es amable
guau qué le estará pasando que le habrá
pasado en la vida para hacer de la forma
en la que es y desarrollas compasión
compasión que no es lástima
sino que se empatía pero no solo es
empatía sino que se empatía acompañada
de amor y profundo respeto al otro
profundo respeto aunque no sepas lo que
le está pasando no porque te das cuenta
que el otro tiene batallas y que el otro
puede ser de la forma en la que quiere
hacer
y entonces con este nuevo acercamiento
entiendes que todos los que te hieren
están heridos que todos los que te hacen
sufrir llevan adentro sufrimiento y la
compasión hace que sientas ese
sufrimiento ajeno como propio y que te
mueva algo en el estómago y quisieras
ayudar a esa persona y te das cuenta que
muchas veces la mayoría no puedes
ayudarlo así que decides que si no
puedes ayudarlo al menos no lo vas a
lastimar
con esa sabiduría que te da la compasión
para comprender lo incomprensible y
perdonar lo imperdonable tú te das
cuenta que la forma más coherente de
vivir es siendo amable
y además una vez que te has empoderado
que te has hecho responsable de cómo te
sientes ya no te sientes preso de las
personas ni de las situaciones y te das
cuenta de que todo lo que te pasa el
lugar en el que te encuentras y las
cosas que te suceden son nada más que
una proyección de ti mismo entonces si
encuentras drama es probable que sea
dramático
y si los demás se pelean contigo es
probable que tú te peleas con ellos y
aquí muchos me discuten y me dicen no
pero es que yo no me peleo son los demás
que se pelean conmigo
y yo quiero que te cuestiones la forma
en la que te enfrentas los
acontecimientos porque si alguien viene
con toda la intención de pelear contigo
y tú le respondes con amabilidad y no le
sigues el juego lo dejas descolocado y
el conflicto no aparece porque el
conflicto necesita de tu atención y tu
energía para existir no hay otra manera
y quería yo decir todo esto porque
entonces lo más inteligente sería vivir
siendo el tipo de personas situaciones y
energía que queremos atraer a nuestra
vida porque recibimos lo que damos y me
encanta esta frase que dice lo que das
te lo das lo que no das te lo quitas
pero no es fácil vivir en base a esto
porque te obliga a hacer tú primero el
que das a ser tu primero el que tomas el
camino menos transitado a ser tu primero
el que te sacrificas pero sobre todo te
ayuda a cultivar una impresionante
aceptación al rechazo porque
porque a veces no recibes lo que das no
inmediatamente no de la persona en la
que esperas no en la cantidad en la que
esperas y eso está bien porque hace que
dejes de estar condicionado a la
respuesta del otro para hacer quien tú
quieres ser y sobre todo está bien
porque te retorna a una verdad
fundamental dar es dar cuando no espera
recibir
y así los amables
aunque no esperan recibir
se dan cuenta mejor que nadie que la
vida es un espejo y que cuando tú eres
bueno y ayudas a los demás los demás son
buenos y te ayudan a ti y que de igual
manera cuando eres una mala persona tú
solito te cierras las oportunidades
porque nunca hay que olvidarse que la
vida da vueltas y si ahora estás arriba
y sientes que no necesitas de la ayuda
de nadie y que eres autosuficiente
este círculo se da la vuelta y te enseña
que puedes estar en una posición donde
necesitas de la bondad ajena por eso
siempre hay que tratar a los demás como
queremos que nos traten
y hay que darnos cuenta de que todas
nuestras ideas y sueños y proyectos se
van a hacer realidad en cuanto seamos
nosotros primero el tipo de persona que
ayudamos a los demás a hacer realidad
sus sueños e ideas y proyectos no hay
otra forma
y el mundo necesita ingenieros
científicos abogados pero sobre todo
necesita gente buena
y no te enseñan en las universidades ni
en los espacios laborales que la
amabilidad es la llave de todas las
puertas está tan subestimada la
amabilidad cuando en realidad es una
herramienta súper práctica porque te
ayuda a ver el mundo de otra manera te
ayuda a ver aliados donde antes veía
rivales te ayuda a no sentir envidia
sino admiración
te enseña a cambiar la crítica
constructiva por la humildad para
aprender y el altruismo para intentar
entonces como no va a ser inteligente
ver a nuestra ciudad como eso como una
plataforma inmensa de posibles aliados
con los que podríamos trabajar para
cambiar las cosas
la amabilidad te acerca a los
desconocidos porque te hace dar cuenta
que no hay tanta gente mala como dice el
noticiero
hay harta gente buena y te enseña a
escuchar al otro y cuando escuchas te
das cuenta de que hay miles de formas de
ver y vivir la vida diferentes a la tuya
y eso te abre la mente te vuelve
empático te vuelve curioso investigas
averiguas osea la amabilidad te vuelve
inteligente
entonces la amabilidad que no es además
una cualidad de seres humanos
extraterrestres porque hay un montón de
estereotipos que rodean esta palabra y
que te hacen pensar que para ser amable
tienes que ser algo así como budista o
hippie o ser puro y santo que nunca te
enojas que nunca gritas y más bien la
amabilidad es algo común y corriente de
personas que si se enojan pero no dejan
que ese enojo los consuma demasiado
tiempo que si gritan pero si lastiman a
alguien son lo suficientemente valientes
para pedir perdón
los amables son estas personas que han
superado el ego que se dan cuenta que el
mundo no gira alrededor de ellos y que
todo lo que encuentran afuera es porque
lo llevan dentro nunca se olvidan la
frase vemos las cosas no como son sino
como somos
y entonces son felices porque no quieren
cambiar a nadie lo que les molesta de
los demás lo corrigen en sí mismos y no
quieren convencer a nadie ellos predican
con el ejemplo
los amables son personas que no
desperdician su energía y tiempo
valiosísimos en cosas inútiles por
ejemplo no pelean no pelean se meten en
enérgicas discusiones desafían
cuestionan pero no pelean porque el
objetivo no es ganar por ganar porque
eso es ego no es tener la razón no es
hacer que los otros piensen como ellos a
ellos les encanta el pensamiento
divergente
y por ejemplo son grandes comunicadores
porque saben decir pero sobre todo saben
escuchar y cuando algo no les parece no
chismear no son lo suficientemente
valientes para decir de frente lo que
piensan y entonces proponen una nueva
idea y se enfocan en ejecutarla
los amables son constructores por
excelencia ellos construyen cuando les
das un problema no lo hacen más grande
lo solucionan
y encuentran encuentran en el grupo de
amigos las semejanzas y no las
diferencias porque buscan la unión y no
la división
y cuando necesitan ayuda son valientes
para pedirla y cuando no saben algo son
valientes para preguntar no tienen
vergüenza
y entonces estos amables se encuentran
las virtudes en nosotros y no las
debilidades y eso hace que sean
carísimos trabajando en equipo haciendo
alianzas y se convierten en grandes
líderes
los amables son inevitablemente
revolucionarios porque no son
indiferentes porque están comprometidos
porque les duele lo que le pasa al otro
porque no les da igual lo que sucede a
su vecino o lo que sucede aquí en
bolivia o en katmandú
los amables tienen grandes ideales viven
según grandes convicciones sueñan sueños
que parecen imposibles así cursi como
suena pero ellos ya no creen en los
límites porque creen en su poder y en el
poder de la comunidad que lo rodea
así los amables contrario a lo que se
cree son todo menos débiles son las
personas más fuertes valientes e
inteligentes que vas a conocer
su vida es una lucha de amor por
construir aquello en lo que creen por
construir la realidad en la que quieren
vivir y sin darse cuenta estos amables
este amable que está dentro de nosotros
y que podemos empezar a hacer hoy
le cambia el día a una persona con un
pequeño acto de amabilidad hace que la
humanidad sea más humana mejora el mundo
y sin duda le da la vuelta al sistema
gracias
[Aplausos]